[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what is
making the headlines with huffpost uk's
political editor kevin schofield and the
spectators deputy political editor katie
balls welcome to both of you with us
until uh just before midnight front
pages though let us start with the
guardian the headline leadership battle
leaves eight tory rivals scrapping for
votes
according to the financial times allies
of boris johnson are poised to throw
their weight behind whichever
conservative leadership candidate seems
best placed to stop rishi sunak
to that end the express reports that
many mps believe liz truss fits that
description the best
indeed the eye suggests mr sunak is the
man to beat
the times says that he and liz troffs
are the two front-runners in the race to
become prime minister the telegraph
highlights the former chancellor's
pledge to run the economy like margaret
thatcher if he wins
but according to the mail party right
wingers are unhappy with what they
describe as his socialist tax plans
looking ahead to the extreme heat
forecast for this weekend coming the
metro proclaims britain on red alert
meanwhile an investigation by the daily
mirror has found that materials intended
for recycling are being flown out of
britain to turkey where they are dumped
and burned
the star remarks on bbc presenters
salaries new figures released today
showed that gary lindecker gets more
than 1.3 million pounds a year for
hosting match of the day
and the sun reports on an entirely
different
boris the tennis champion mr becker who
it's emerged is teaching sports science
while serving a jail sentence
well a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's uh return to our guest
then kevin schofield and katie balls who
are here with us
katie let's kick off with you um sir so
then there were eight uh what do you
make of the list of of contenders
so it's a pretty wide field but i think
we could see that shortened quite
considerably tomorrow
i think that you could see when the
threshold uh increase was announced that
there was some relief it was only at 20.
but the fact you have to have 30
nominations by mps to progress as of
tomorrow does mean i think that's gonna
be quite a short-lived relief in terms
of the candidates lost i think sergeant
javid is probably the biggest surprise i
think rival camps had tried to suggest
to the former health secretary who
better rowing
behind a candidate but he decided to go
himself anything that is having
repercussions in the sense that i don't
think it's boosted his standing amongst
colleagues he'd probably be better to i
think work with another candidate as
opposed to go out for a third time to
run for leader unsuccessfully
and a spare thought for us then kevin of
those who have already dropped by the
wayside pretty patel announcing she was
not running roman shishti clearly did
not have enough support but also grant
shaps and sajid javid uh right at the
last minute before the deadline closed
yes as katie says i think that was the
big surprise um satya javid obviously
high profile got decent name recognition
probably one of the few
um in the race that the ordinary man and
women in the street would have would
have heard of so yeah that would be a
big disappointment for him he only
launched his campaign yesterday so not
to make on the ballot paper is a little
bit embarrassing actually uh the others
probably not as surprising that they
have fallen by the wayside but again as
as katie said
the big hurdle now is to get 30. um
previous
election total elections have meant that
basically the person who finished bottom
falls off the ballot will have raised
the bar now so that you can finish
bottom and also and you can fall off if
you don't hit 30 and that's quite a high
bar to clear and i think some of them
who only just got past 20 maybe
something like jeremy hunt the deems of
harley i think they might be looking uh
pretty um vulnerable tomorrow so uh so
yeah we're at eight at the moment but i
think maybe by this time tomorrow we
could be another three or four down and
then we move on to thursday yes and uh
the guardian um you know talks about the
rivals scrapping for votes uh sunak the
front runner with support of more than
40 colleagues javid drops out but of
course tomorrow will be a secret ballot
i guess they don't need to say how
they're going to vote do they the
financial times as well eight make the
tour ballot as allies of johnson step up
a stop rishi push
will he be one of the final two what's
your betting katie
i think he's in a good place to be in
the final two i think we've seen so many
surprises in uk politics people want to
bet
everything on that happening and but it
does seem right now that richard has
plenty of momentum behind him i think
the fact that he was probably the first
uh big name of the of the candidates to
come out um has helped him and the
numbers are much higher than the other
camps now i think tomorrow as you say
when we actually see because lots of mps
have not declared yet yes more than not
have but there's still you know around
over a hundred you have not done that so
until we see tomorrow where mps are i
think that's where i'm gonna have the
clearest sense but right now definitely
the sense amongst other leadership
campaigns is about trying to get the
spot in the final two opposite rishi
sunak which i think is what is helping
some candidates like liz truss who are
pitching themselves as the as the
figures who can stop sunak from winning
yes and indeed uh the delhi express
picks up on that that boris loyalists
have backed liz trust to stop rishi with
sauna dean doris didn't we and jacob
rees-mogg coming out you know and the
narrative was quite clear it was rishi's
higher taxes you know not not
collectively agreed by cabinet and
signed off by the prime minister
how do you see this battle shaping up
and why is it about
tax and spend when there are many other
issues to discuss kevin
yeah well i mean traditionally
conservatives love low taxes and um
which is ironic obviously given that
we've had a conservative government for
the last 12 years and taxes are at their
highest level in decades so um so yeah
people like jacob reese mogg nadine
doris james cleverley as well who came
out to date the back and let's trust
they are training their their guns on
racist saying that he's made a mess of
the economy taxes are too high he's not
a proper conservative i mean jacob smog
rather bizarrely has described she's
unique as a socialist which is probably
the first time for everything but um but
yeah they they see this as rishi sunak's
uh weakness um the high tax rates that
we have in the country at the moment and
they think obviously that tory members
will agree and will be wooed by a
candidate who um pledges to reduce taxes
and um implement brexit maybe in the way
that people like jacobi's mob would like
to see it implementing so i think that
is going to be versus great weakness in
terms of um getting his point across
however what i'm sure we're going to
come on to in the telegraph tomorrow he
talks about how and he was seeing it um
earlier today as well actually that the
tax cuts will come he says it's not a
question of of if but when however he
will only do it when the economy can
afford it um whereas the others are
saying let's tax cut let's cut taxes um
as soon as possible so that i think is
going to be the big ideological battle
as the um contest progresses yes uh
responsibly was the word he used today
wasn't it katie so let's take a look at
the daily telegraph shall we giving they
say his first campaign interview the
former chancellor likens thatcher's
upbringing above her father's grocery
shop to his own childhood spent helping
in his mother's pharmacy and tell us
more about how he's outlined how he
might be prime minister in this article
yes um this is not the first of the tory
leadership hopefuls to compare
themselves to margaret thatcher you can
think about liz trust and some of her
recent photo ops but rishi scenic is
trying to use thatcher as an example on
the economy and effectively saying that
he will cut taxes but only responsible
tax cuts
and so it has to be done when the time
is right and i think this is interesting
because one of richie's next big
weaknesses in the tory dealership
campaign is the fact that others around
him are offering probably uh easier
policies to sell in the form of
immediate tax parts
and he is having to char probably a more
unpopular course but so far actually has
somehow managed to shape the debate
around him and go out on that which
means i think he looks less on the
defensive in other circumstances but i
do think if richard cena does make it to
the final two he's gonna have to you
know change gears and actually have a
message which is hopeful and
inspirational it doesn't have to be on
tax but he needs something else to say
other than that he is not going to
attack um cut taxes as quickly as others
and also um you know being drawn into
you know the the accusation of betrayal
and disloyalty last week suggesting that
he left government because it was not no
longer working and paying tribute in
fact to boris johnson kevin
yeah that was that was quite um
eye-catching as well what he was saying
about about boris jones because clearly
he sees that as a weakness as well you
know regardless of um the
prime minister outgoing prime minister's
unpopularity i think there are still a
lot of conservative party members who
probably still have quite a lot of time
for boris johnson and russia students
sees that as as a weakness he doesn't
want to be painted as the anti-boris
candidate and so he was very effusive
and he's in his praise actually uh of
boris johnson today said he was uh he
had a he had a good heart um uh which
rather begs the question or why did you
leave his cabinet last week saying
basically you could no longer serve
under him but yeah he was trying today i
think to to sort of smooth the rough
edges around his campaign in terms of
tax cutting and his um treatment of
boris johnson as we saw jacob eastmog
clearly in particular and nadine doris
this evening though they're still pretty
bruised i think by boris johnson losing
his job they believe rishi sunak accused
him of plotting against him for for the
last few months um and he's obviously
trying to as a service he's not trying
to get um not not lose anyway as many
pro boris voters as he possibly can we
we talked last week katie um about how
this is a sort of battle for the soul of
the conservative party and if it does
shape down to rishi on one side and a
candidate of the right on the other then
what what is rishi sunak in in sort of
in terms of historical conservative
candidacy
well i think what's really striking is
that you look at what could be a final
tour of rishi sooner and there's trust
in which case liz trust be seen as a
candidate on the right
yet this trust voted remain rishi soon
activated leave
rishi suneka's arguing to be a fiscal
conservative
um to be disciplined and others in the
race talking about more or they're at
least implying about borrowing to fund
tax cuts it's quite interesting where
we've got to in terms of who's on the
right who's in the center ground and i
think if you look at some of the back as
rishi suning
so former chancellors
lamont you also have you know figures
like william hague i think that russian
is coming across more as the
establishment figure in that final two
and actually if there is a candidate on
the right i think they'll be seen as
more radical by comparison
so um just looking ahead to tomorrow um
the vote starts at uh 1 30. you know
who's going to in your view kevin who
might be shaken out of the system
tomorrow
my goodness my political protections
tend to blow up in my face but um i mean
as i said ella i think jeremy hunt
um and uh nadine zahavi are probably
looking quite vulnerable um it's gonna
be interesting to see which of
cami bad knock obviously is is
generating a lot of interest a lot of
buzz around her campaign suella
braverman as well uh has i think in the
background so off the potential
challenge of pretty patel to be seen as
the brexiteer
uh
uh conservative with our very capital c
um candidate i think
they'll probably get through but it's
gonna be very very dicey i think it's
gonna be a lot easier to predict he will
definitely go through people like as
we've talked about risky soon liz trust
penny morden tom toucan hat i think
they're pretty much assured to go
through for the others it's going to be
a little bit um
interesting a pretty nervy a couple
hours for them and once that a result
was announced shortly after 3 30
tomorrow but um yeah i think they'll be
we'll shed at least three tomorrow and
then by next monday when we have the
next sorry by thursday every time we get
to next monday i think we could be very
close to getting down to the final two
yeah exactly and just very quickly katie
you as well who do you think might go
tomorrow
yeah i mean i broadly agree in the sense
i think the candidates that appear to be
struggling today jim sahary jeremy hunt
and then i think if you're looking at
the right of the party it feels the
endorsement of nadine doris jacob reese
wong has helped liz trust
so can uh both serla bravement and
kemmie bajnal both get 30 i would
perhaps only one will be able to do that
and that could eventually help to unify
the block on the right of the party to
get their candidate which could have
been something like penny warden could
struggle to get to the final two
well the two people who used to be uh
newspaper reviewers like you two tonight
have already gone uh that is raymond
shishti and grant shaps who who did it
for a long time in fact uh they're
already out of the competition we will
certainly have full coverage of that uh
tomorrow stay there both for you lots
more to talk about including uh this
heat does the record heat forecast for
this weekend weren't a national state of
emergency
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now kevin schofield and
katie balls welcome back to both of you
um so it's hot and it's uh well it's
cooling down but it's gonna get hotter
isn't it kevin uh front page of the uh
metro britain on red alert um talking
about the prospect of the hottest day
ever in parts of the uk
yeah i mean
for those of us um who were brought up
in scotland just like katie
it's not been much fun being in london
the last couple of days and the idea
that it's going to get even worse
over the weekend is frankly terrifying
and um yeah i mean obviously with this
it brings
obvious
problems train something to run
more slowly extra pressure on the nhs as
people particularly vulnerable people
older people struggle in this heat and
you know anyone who doesn't think that
the climate change climate change as an
actual thing maybe this might make them
realize that perhaps it is after all uh
it is quite um extraordinary the
intensity of the heat right now and that
sadly
it's only going to get worse and then i
think it's going to be a good while
before we manage to get get through this
particular heat wave yes uh continent
too um certainly uh you know we sent to
portugal where there's a series of
wildfires but you mentioned the health
service um telegraph and elsewhere
talking about the ambulance trusts on
the highest alert overheat but also
covid kt ambulance trust declaring the
highest state of alert citing extreme
pressure as this heat wave continues um
suggesting that uh people people are
being urged to only call 999 if the
matter is life-threatening so very
difficult pressures we're seeing
yes completely and if we're being honest
the country is just not used to being in
the high 30s when it comes to the
temperature
and so if we do hit that and we're
expecting to dip before the weekend but
then go up again and people will perhaps
have to adjust their behaviors and
therefore it's doing
when to call when to do things and it's
going to put a strain on lots of
services
and also just the general overgoing i
mean i struggle even with the
temperature the past few days that alone
if it gets as high as being predictive
when it comes to the weekend
uh and pressure two at airports still uh
the ft uh talking about this heathrow uh
capping flight ticket sales
throughout the summer uh kevin 100 000
only suggesting that 125 000 uh
passengers left that airport a day
before the pandemic and so once again
we're seeing some very disappointed
travelers
absolutely and there's already been
obviously a lot of people affected by um
flight cancellations thus far and in the
summer so the idea that it's going to be
even worse um is is
terrible really i mean people have saved
up all year i have had a very tough
couple years maybe they've not been
abroad since before the pandemic and now
discovering that there are flights that
they've already paid for in some cases
aren't going to take off um it's just
truly awful um and it doesn't look as
though it's going to get better any time
soon this is obviously a hangover from
the pandemic airlines and the airports
laid off a lot of staff when
global travel ground to a halt and
the aviation industry has has taken off
if you pardon upon much more quickly uh
post pandemic than was expected and they
don't have the staff numbers to cope so
even the people who have been lucky
enough to get away i faced awful delays
and picking up their baggage when they
get to their destinations um but at
least they are getting away um whereas
and now it looks as though hundreds if
not thousands more people per day are
going to be um very very let down by the
fact that the flights aren't even going
to take off and the left haven't
scrambled around trying to make
alternative arrangements so uh so yeah
it's going to be a pretty tough tough
summer and also all this is obviously
coming against the backdrop of a
government which is in complete limbo
the government's really not not able to
do much until a new prime minister is in
place and that's not going to happen
until the 5th of september yeah we'll
see what else does not get tackled shall
we um you want to do the sun as well
i'll just
show it boris gets a new job um the
fallen tv star uh the son tells us has
landed himself a new job teaching fellow
lags as the paper puts it sports science
so there we are we will no doubt him
more about that a little later but for
now kevin schofield katie balls thank
you both very much indeed thank you
and we'll certainly see you throughout
the next part of our program next day
we've got the weather